so there have been a ton of leaks lately
in regards to Avengers 4 but I think one
of the coolest leaks that we've gotten
so far is a new design for Iron Man's
armor the armor is being called the mark
85 and although we only have a little
bit of information on it it's really
exciting to see that Iron Man is going
to have a new armor in Avengers 4 I'm
still giving away copies of infinity war
and ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray and
some special edition posters all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
like I said some of the leaks that we've
gotten lately are photos of Iron Man's
new red and gold armor it's a little
different than what I earn man war an
infinity war which was the mark 50 the
mark 50 was nanotechnology so that
probably means that the mark 85 is going
to be nanotechnology as well we know
this because the Russo brothers have
stated that the mark 50 nanotech suit is
the most technologically advanced suit
that Tony Stark is capable of creating
so it would make sense that the mark 85
would be nanotech as well and if we look
at this leaked photo of the arc reactor
of the new suit it looks almost
identical to the mark 50 suit that he
wore in Avengers infinity war which
means that this is most likely a housing
unit for nanobots the armor also has
significantly more gold in it this is
most likely a tribute to the Iron Man
mark 4 armor which is one of the most
classic armors from the comics this
makes sense because Avengers 4 is set to
wrap up the first 10 years of the MCU
and since iron man was the one that
started it all off 10 years ago it would
make sense that they paid tribute to
such an iconic suit although the suit is
nanotech it has most likely gone through
some modifications and enhancements with
its energy and weaponry it's widely
believed that the events of Avengers 4
will actually take place several years
after the events of Avengers infinity
war this gives Ironman several years to
come up with more modifications and
enhancements for his new suit and since
he's already fought Thanos and lost he
knows exactly what he needs to upgrade
and enhance to be able to stand a chance
against Thanos
the number of the armor is also worth
mentioning as I mentioned in infinity
war Ironman had the mark 50 now we jump
to the mark 80
five that's a 35 mark gap it's possible
that Tony Stark has actually made all of
these suits and has assembled the iron
Legion again this makes sense because
our heroes got their butts kicked in
Avengers for Tony specifically Tony had
been preparing for Thanos his attacks
since the Battle of New York and the
first Avengers movie he thought that his
armor would be enough to defeat Thanos
but it wasn't but if he had an iron
Legion of 30 different Iron Man armors
and they joined him in the battle
against Thanos perhaps that could be
enough so I really look forward to
seeing Iron Man's new red and gold
classic armor in Avengers 4 and I also
look forward to see what kind of
upgrades he gives it and I also hope we
see the iron Legion as well
shout out to ultra rah 26 for this
awesome design of what Iron Man's mark
85 armor could look like in Avengers 4
you can check him out on Instagram let
me know what you all think of Iron Man's
mark 85 armor and let me know how
excited you are to see it in Avengers 4
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video for your chance to win
the giveaway and so you can stay up to
date on everything related to Avengers 4
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]